[Music]
welcome back to the special edition of
Hannity now more bad news for the green
New Deal cult construction of Ford's
electric vehicle battery plant in
Michigan was halted back in September
due to concerns over costs and today
Ford announced they are moving forward
with a project but with production
capabilities cut by 40% and the number
of jobs it is projected to create
slashed by more than 30% their
announcement comes as sales of electric
vehicles have slowed across the country
forcing numerous automakers to scale
back operations Ford's announcement is
the latest blow to the Biden
Administration and further proof the
American people aren't buying into his
administration's green energy agenda
here now with reaction Hoover Institute
fellow Victor David Hansen all right
Victor now Americans really don't want
electric cars I I'll start with that as
a premise tell us what's going on
well I think we have a lot of utopians
Judge and they are not attuned to Market
realities so they keep saying you have
to have in 10 years uh half of all car
sales or all car sales actually in
California have to be electric already a
quarter of all sales are electric but
it's not Market driven it's driven by
bureaucrats and now people buy them they
don't have the range of a gas car they
tend to be more flammable they're
dangerous when you get in an accident
they're a third heavier so they're sort
of like Torpedoes on the road they're
very dangerous and more importantly how
are you going to power them if you're
not going to build hydroelectric nuclear
gas or coal and people are going to
charge at night there's wind and solar
won't do it so I think the real subtext
of all of this dilemma is that they
don't want a private car powered by a
fossil fuel and they went to EV as a
substitute and the substitute didn't
work and now we're starting to hear that
the real agenda is to get us into
High-Speed Rail buses mass transit
Subways and deal get away with the
private vehicle altogether because the
EV is not going to replace uh what we
have now so they have a different agenda
here in California electricity prices
went up 133% they're going to go up 133%
at the beginning of the year and that's
just one year four times the rate of
inflation and you know and they're
talking about Judge can you believe it
you plug your car and they want you to
power the grid from your battery at
night well the amazing part of it is I
mean when you think about it I mean if
you look at a street in many cities all
these cars are lined up they don't have
individual power stations to power up
their cars I mean so it's it's almost
impossible but if there is another
president who comes in in 2024 I mean
does this all come to an end I mean can
we switch back to fossil fuels how does
this work yeah I I think so because 99%
of the emissions from fossil fuel cars
are not toxic the the the rub or the
complaint against them is they create
heat but if you don't believe
necessarily that man-made climate change
uh is is that severe then I think you'll
see a return to natural gas or hydrogen
or gasoline or diesel there's all sorts
of fuels that they can use and they're
all safer and I think they're more
economical than electricity batteries
you know I've never felt like I lived in
a totalitarian uh uh Nation but you know
when they started talking about taking
away my gas stove I'm a cook I mean it
was like I'll I'll fight him every inch
of the way uh but it is not what the
American people want and we have spent
billions in the infrastructure uh uh act
and that really is a sad commentary on
Joe Biden his connection to China and
those batteries that we are buying from
over there that we can't even dispose of
properly because of the danger to to the
environment no and we and we need
lithium mines and we're trying to stop
mining of precious rare metals to to
power these batteries and here in
California it's a future so Gavin Nome
wants to do to America what he did to
California we're not having it that's
frightening idea Victor David Hansen
thanks so much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else